sinister is one of the better big-budget
horror movies in recent memory and
nobody was surprised when this Blum
House film got the sequel treatment in
2015 but since then there hasn't been so
much as a whisper about a third chapter
instead it looks like the whole sinister
series has been abandoned in favor of
other franchises
why does sequel happy Hollywood want
nothing more to do with McCool in his
box of haunted videos let's roll the
tape sinister 2 didn't make enough cash
producer Jason Blum knows a thing or two
about getting a series off the ground
he's the man who made one-off movies
like Paranormal Activity insidious in
the purge into successful multi film
franchises but when asked about the
prospect of a third sinister movie
during a Facebook live chat in 2016
Blum was brutally honest saying we
didn't do well enough with sinister -
not enough people went to see sinister -
to make sinister 3 which is really sad
if you're wondering what sad looks like
in terms of cold hard numbers
the original sinister made 77 million on
a three million dollar budget the sequel
which cost more than three times as much
to make brought in only 52 million
critics tour the second film apart so
why did audiences not latch on to
sinister - the way they did for the
original not to be blunt but probably
because it was a bad movie at least
according to critics Wesley Morris of
grantland's summed it up best writing
there comes a point when you have to say
no to these horror sequels there's no
skill or idea visible anywhere just the
sound of money being sucked from your
pockets and he wasn't alone even critics
who liked the first sinister movie
thought this one was cheap unbelievable
and most of all unnecessary the sequel
botched the best part like the first
movie sinister to centers around a
series of snuff films each involving the
grisly murder of what appears to be an
entire family and in the first film
these sequences were so disturbing that
it kind of felt like we shouldn't even
be seeing them which made it a highly
effective horror movie if not the source
of a few recurring nightmares
but in sinister to the murder films
looked more like crudely shot B movies
screened with a bargain bin horror
soundtrack that took them over the line
from creepy to cheesy
with the scariest part of sinister
effectively ruined by the sequel it's no
surprise that Hollywood preferred not to
unbox any future home videos from babul
they killed the premise and the whole
cast after the original sinister ended
with a huge reveal that the movies snuff
films were made by kids who killed their
own families while under the influence
of an ancient boogeyman sinister 2 tried
to do something different with the
source of the movies no longer a mystery
the sequel took a new angle focusing on
one kid is he's courted by the ghostly
squad of child murderers who want him to
join their ranks and taking all the
mystery out of the premise that made
sinister scary in the first place oops
on top of that both of these movies end
with the deaths of virtually every major
character which is appropriately dark
for a horror film but not so good for a
horror franchise with nobody left alive
to star in a new installment sinister 3
would have to start from scratch
creating a whole new set of characters
to breathe life into a tired storyline
the monster is a bore this is a problem
that started with sinister and never got
fixed
but ghoul is more than just an
unpronounceable name he's a lousy
character to some cultures believed that
it lived in another realm reachable only
by ritual or sacrifice whatever that
means both movies identify the ghoul
also known as the boogeyman as an
otherworldly being who exists to corrupt
innocent children but is the antagonist
of a major horror franchise we never
really get to know the ghoul his hopes
his dreams his reasons for dressing up
like a low-rent Michael Jackson
impersonator sure he makes for a good
jump scare but without a compelling
villain to shape the franchise around
making more sinister movies would be a
chore especially when competing series
like the conjuring are trotting out
fresh interesting monsters with
legitimate backstories on the regular
the original director has moved on
sinister director scott derrickson
doesn't do generic horror and he's
especially good at translating classic
subject matter into something freshly
terrifying
that would make him the perfect person
to get this spooky series back on track
if only he had the time for it but
derrickson let someone else take the
reins when it came to directing sinister
- and by the time the sequel hit
theaters he was already on to bigger
things specifically the Marvel movie
Doctor Strange which catapulted him into
a whole new world of big-budget
high-profile projects between adapting
bong joon-ho snowpiercer into a TV
series and probably helming the
inevitable Doctor Strange sequel
derrickson has plenty on his plate and
he isn't likely to waste his energy
trying to bring small-budget babul and
his squad of killer kiddos back from the
dead or wherever they are so when it
comes to more sinister sequels it looks
like the hero from sinister 2 gets the
last word it's over Zak you're not
making a film thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love -
[Music]
[Applause]